hello my name is kim elaine and today
i'm gonna have two chefs compete to make
my
dream dessert
hi i'm alexis i'm kayla nice to meet you
i'm matthew nice to meet you i love your
glasses thank you if you could come up
with any dish in the world what would it
be a cookie cupcake so when kayla said
she wanted to do a cupcake i was really
happy but then she kept going and put
like the chocolatey flavor cupcake no
not the cupcake but the cookie the
cookie so chocolate with like white
chocolate chips in it okay it's like a
chocolate mix yeah then you put the
glaze and then you put the cupcake
on top of the glaze yeah brought it and
got it and then on to what's on top of
this cupcake the glazed and the cookie
okay the glaze again the whole layering
aspect of this like cookie cupcake
contraption that's when i got worried
the pink frosting okay like strawberry
strawberry that sounds good
then you put the like the other
thing the other flavor the other layer
yeah because like the the they cut it in
half right
i'm wondering about the size like is it
going to topple over maybe i should make
something bigger or maybe like a mini do
you like any like decorations do you
want it to be simple or do you want it
to be like kind of wild well not like
why wow
[Music]
i think chocolate cupcake white
chocolate chocolate cookies and
strawberries are a great mashup as long
as the structural integrity stays intact
we'll be good do you think we can do it
yes okay cool a lot i think we should go
do it
we've got cookie on the bottom
glaze
cupcake half
more glaze
cookie
frosting
cupcake half and more frosting am i
feeling confident i think i'll get there
i'm going to first make a really nice
round chocolate cake then have some
great strawberry buttercream frosting
then a giant chocolate cookie with white
chocolate chips more frosting another
layer of chocolate cake i'll put
frosting with a lot of great garnishes
like fresh strawberries matthew is an
amazing cook he does really great work
he's going to be a good competitor i'm
gonna make a really moist chocolate cake
put some strawberry glaze on it a cookie
that fits perfectly on top frosting
strawberries cake and then repeat alexis
will do her best i know i'm gonna do my
best but i hope i come out on top
i'm starting with my chocolate white
chocolate chip cookies and then gonna
move on to the cupcake that i'm turning
into just a normal chocolate cake i too
am starting my cookies and then making
like a mini six inch cake i just sifted
my two flowers i'm using
regular flour and bread flour so i'm
gonna brown the butter so it's gonna get
this like really dark nutty color it'll
boil down a bit since some of the fat
cooks off
so i just added a bit of water to bring
it back up to a cup now i'm going to add
the sugars so adding brown sugar
white sugar
and then we're going to add brown butter
oh my god that looks amazing so right
now i'm starting with the butter brown
sugar and regular white sugar to cream
together for my cookies and now i'm
adding the eggs flour cocoa powder
baking soda so i'm pushing my cookie
dough into the same size cake tin that
my cake will be baked in so that way
they're all evenly sized in order to do
some cool decorations on top i think i
might make like some interestingly
shaped cookies what i want to try to do
is make a little like cookie sign that i
can like stick in the cake and it'll say
kayla on it that's so cute if i can
somehow spell her name out in white
chocolate do you want to try this
it's good watch out for this
it's really good they're both really
good
you have more of a chocolate cookie i do
yes so that's also going to be different
okay cool
i'm just going to
chip on chip one ice cream scoop equals
one cookie but since i want this to be
bigger maybe three
go big or go home
i'm going into the oven now
here we go
[Music]
i mean so far i feel i feel pretty good
she didn't do exactly what i think
kayla wanted with the cookie i think
maybe kayla was looking for that
chocolate cookie with the white
chocolate chips that's what i'm aiming
for while you were gone they tried to
get me to like say some mean things
about you did you say anything no
i was like considering thinking like i
could be like
bring it on
but that's like so not my nature i'm
doing the same creaming thing for the
cake just like i did for the cookie just
to help it aid a little bit and it's
being a little bit more liquidy i'm
going to add a little bit of oil as well
i am going to
boil water and then add cocoa powder to
it as my first step to the cake the hot
water with the cocoa powder is gonna
make more intense flavor than if you
just added plain cocoa powder or if you
added cocoa powder to cold water i'm
gonna sift the flour baking soda sugar
and salt so now adding the cocoa now
that my cake batter is done i'm putting
them into these cake tins and so it's
actually interesting
to see how different our batters are
yours is much more thick and actually
looks more cake like whereas mine is
like pretty liquidy i'm gonna start on
my glaze and i'm going to use a ricer
to actually mash the strawberries
i realize this looks kind of gross
but it's just an easy way to get it all
kind of pulpy and now i'm going to move
on to making the strawberry buttercream
i'm not creamy necessarily the butter
anymore it's more just like kind of
aerating it and then adding the
freeze-dried strawberries that i've
crushed up and that's gonna give me a
really bright pink strawberry frosting
oh yeah mmm almost like celery ice cream
okay that is so good thank you i'm gonna
start on my buttercream i'm going to add
powdered sugar vanilla
again salt
strawberry and raspberry jam
wow that's sweet i think we're at like
the easy part that we've all done before
which is like make
frostings cakes and cookies the layering
and like the decoration is what i'm not
as confident about i feel really
confident flavor-wise i feel like the
decorating what is a nine-year-old like
i don't know maybe i'm terrible with
kids and i just didn't know it
i'm really excited for kayla to try my
cake i think it looks so pretty and i
have all these little touches i think
she'll really take to heart i tasted the
cookie and the cake and i like how it
tastes i just hope it's enough to win
her vote i will say that i think my
chocolate cake might seal the deal
it's so moist and it's so fluffy um
and i just think when she has a bite of
it it'll be hard it'll be hard to say no
okay youtube what do you got for me we
have our cakes they're a little
different from what you drew but i hope
they're good i hope so this is really
tall
it's like a big tall tower oh gosh
i feel pretty happy with the cake it
looks like what she drew and i think
she's gonna like it so you know we've
got the chocolatey layers there's a
strawberry glaze there's the chocolate
chip cookies with white and semi-sweet
chocolate
this is good
tastes like chocolate
with chocolate and it's still moist i
think she's really into my chocolate
cake so right here we have all these
really fun emojis for you if you had to
describe the cake you just tried which
one would you choose
that one oh
thank you oh that's such a compliment
kayla is about to try my cake and i'm
really excited i know she's gonna love
it i think the cookie with her name on
top is really gonna push it over the
edge here is a simple chocolate cake and
then inside there is a strawberry
buttercream frosting cool
oh gosh it tastes like a brownie
it's so hard
so this is the cookie part and then you
gotta try the cake by itself too
that's good so kayla you've chosen my
emoji but now you've got to choose maths
um
i'll take it i'll take it i love it i
love hard eyes do you need to try
anything else before you make your final
decision i can give you a huge bite of
that yeah
oh my god that's so precious
laying it on thick matthew laying it on
fish
this is good this is the best cookie
i've ever had
whoa
i think
the winner is
number one
thanks caleb
you did great too
oh finally
you know i really needed this win oh
i lost
i expected her to really not notice the
nuances that i could have put into the
cake so i kept it really simple and
focused on the decoration but maybe i
should have taken those extra moments to
really put in all the extra pizzazz and
flavor into the cake and the cookie
itself because you're the winner you get
a big
thank you so much this is amazing this
is so so sweet it kind of it kind of
looks like it right yeah yeah kind of i
feel pretty good what am i going to do
this hanging over my bed put in my
living room send it to my mom i don't
know i'm pretty proud though do you want
to try
doing that
[Music]
you